all right so you've seen the trailer for
this one
a lot
the movie's finally out
[Music]
so bullet trains directed by david leach
it stars brad pitt yes it does but also
a lot of other actors comprising a lot
of other characters that are very fun
and colorful otherwise murderous
characters they're hitmen or otherwise
people who deal
in that kind of a world they've all come
together on this bullet train and for
the next two hours they're clashing
scheming or otherwise navigating through
the tangled web that is their lives and
their careers and we're all along for
the ride simple synopsis yes but it's as
accurate as it needs to be and judging
from the trailer if i'm just assessing
what the trailer looked like the trailer
looks like it's john wick meets murder
on the orient express
with the director of deadpool 2. that's
not really the movie the action's in it
absolutely is it a stylistic movie
without a doubt is the action fun and
satisfying as it's going down absolutely
it is but i felt like the core of the
movie was all these characters
traversing the tangled web that is the
plot and trying to manipulate and scheme
each other to do so and i will say i
really loved the characters in the movie
because none of the characters really
felt like the other characters it's not
like you have tough hitman a and tough
hitman b and they're kind of
interchangeable yeah the actress
director the movie it all does a good
job at making the characters feel unique
and distinct i always like that reminds
me of a good jrpg where you're like i
have a nice amount of characters and
none of them feel like the other ones
they're unique tell a movie like this
should feel it's shocking how many
movies don't pull that off and as much
as brad pitt crushes it it's easy to say
that he's a standout because he is the
main character but he does do a great
job in the movie i want to give some
special love to brian tyree henry and
aaron taylor johnson there's a couple of
guys with three names making youtubers
get tongue tied they were these
standouts in the movie i dare to say
when i was having the most fun in here
was when they were bantering their
banter in their chemistry it is electric
in fact
if there's a standalone movie with those
two i would totally be down i genuinely
think that there's a stand-alone
spin-off film with those two that i
would totally watch also i appreciate
the fact this movie does it keeps you
guessing you know it's not like one of
those moves like i knew where it was
going in act one however flip side of
that enjoyable coin it's convoluted plot
is it convoluted and overly padded
sometimes the movie has a style to it
too sometimes is it overly stylistic
like in a way that you feel like you're
you're burning the clock sometimes this
movie kind of does throw back to this
block of time that i feel like was more
brief than some of us remember
2004-2006 like those action crime movies
that were super stylistic maybe over the
top but it was just kind of it was the
point like someone was in high school
when they saw pulp fiction or snatch and
they were like i'm gonna do that but i'm
gonna go crazy definitely as a smoke and
aces vibe when i was watching the movies
like this kind of reminds me of smoking
aces differences smoking aces those
those movies i'm talking about from that
time they had that grit that late 90s to
mid 2000s grit this movie doesn't have
that there's no mistake it's like if you
watch this movie it's like yeah that was
filmed in 2022 for sure regardless there
was something that was smoking aces
meets the director of deadpool 2. there
was a point in the movie where i was
like if the movie ended not necessarily
ended at this point but ended at this
time it would have been perfect about
the 90 minute mark and the movie looked
like it was wrapping up i was like oh a
movie with perfect timing thank wow we
have another half an hour oh it's not
wrapping up okay granted the last half
hour of this movie is batshit it's nuts
it's a lot of fun it leaves the audience
with that action so i feel like that's
where people are coming out of the movie
theater like whoa crazy action but i
enjoyed the [ __ ] out of that
that that was fun guys in the end bullet
train it's not like it's not the movie
of the year i wanted this to be on my
top 10. what can i say amanda wants
regardless i felt the movie was a fun
time it had colorful characters it kept
you guessing when the fights went down
those were fun but as you've been
listening to this whole video and you
didn't skip to the rating because i know
you totally didn't do that i guess you
didn't if you're listening to this part
thank you just know you if you want to
see a movie that's a throwback or a love
letter to those mid-2000s stylized crime
action movies this is that and i walked
out of this movie having a fun time no
alcohol required funny i feel like i
should use the matinee price marcus good
time no alcohol required i feel like
it's not what it always was before now
i'm saying pay these gas prices to get
to the movie theater then pay movie
theater prizes for the ticket you gotta
really want it now but i just thought
but i digress there's a bullet train
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
i want to give some special love to
brian tyree henry
want to give some special love to brian
tyree henry and eric
i want to give some special love to
brian hi reid
that was a different name wanna give
some special love to brian tyree henry
and aaron taylor johnson i want to get
some special love to brian
i want to get some special love to brian
tyree henry and aaron taylor johnson
that's as good as he's getting